well what you see I think when you have
a relationship with a child that your
own child in particular because you can
see them most clearly in some real sense
is that you see the
manifestation of the image of God it's
not something you treat lightly it's not
something that isn't miraculous if you
take children seriously and if you take
the task of creating a world in which
little human beings can turn into
healthy whole responsible good adults
who can live full-rounded satisfying
lives that are not just good for
themselves but good for the other people
around them you know that's again I have
to turn to the sacred language like this
is a sacred task
and to see people so willfully tell
small children lies
I I feel livid at these people really
livid yeah I I feel exactly the same
well hence my Banning from Twitter let's
say
[Music]
hello everyone I'm here today with
author and journalist
Helen Joyce
her first book
trans
when ideology meets reality was a times
of London bestseller in 20
21 she is a long time staff journalist
at The Economist
where she has held various senior
positions including Britain editor
International editor and finance editor
she is currently on leave of absence
from The Economist to work with sex
matters a new human rights organization
campaigning for sex-based rights thank
you very much for agreeing to speak with
me Helen and I been reading your book
over the last couple of days and found
it
um what would you call it unfortunately
compelling that might be the right term
and this issue of uh the transsexual
rights and and all of the fewer and
upheaval around them seems in some odd
way key to the malaise that is Central
to our times and so people have asked me
like they've asked you why I've bothered
dealing with it at all since it's
hypothetically doesn't affect me
personally but maybe we can start with
that because at the beginning of your
book you pointed out that
well writing this wasn't exactly good
for your reputation let's say uh
certainly exposed you to the mad
uh
uh affections of the mob let's say and
but on the other hand as we noted in
your biography you are a journalist
after all so maybe we could start with
your your thoughts on why this book was
necessary and and uh Timely
well first of all thank you for having
me on it's really kind of you to talk to
me about it and I think unfortunately
compelling is perhaps the the best two
words description of my book I've heard
yet
and so why did I write it
I mean I've been a journalist now for
approaching 20 years and I think a
journalist a short description would be
somebody who runs towards the burning
building rather than away from it
so when you see something that's crazy
compelling a moving story big news you
shouldn't say oh this is going to be
trouble this is going to be difficult to
write about you should go oh tell me
more
and then when you start to interview
people and you get reactions of the
sorts that you've never had before and
you know for your listeners I've um I've
been a foreign correspondent I've worked
in Brazil I've I've written about
pedophilia I've written about the
effects of pornography on teenagers
brains I've interviewed murderers I've
interviewed presidents
and never before have I had the reaction
that I had for this
yeah well that's also why I thought that
well that's why I thought that opening
with that background was so relevant
because you have this immense experience
as a journalist and you've covered all
sorts of controversial issues and yet
you haven't been exposed to the kind of
vitriol that this book attracted and so
I guess there's two questions about that
one is why in the world would this be
such a hot button issue but but also a
heart but an issue associated with that
kind of mobbing and vitriol and What
technological Transformations say social
media related do you think might be also
contributing to the fact that uh someone
like you can be targeted so effectively
for communicating
for communicating now yeah two really
good questions I think that one of the
reasons that the vitriol is so intense
on this subject is that it's so
linguistic
you know when you say that men can
become women by saying that they're
women or vice versa you're making a
statement about language not about
reality
and in the post the post-modernist turn
is precisely that turn in which the
language takes precedence over the
Bedrock material
it's itchness of things and so when
somebody like me insists on talking
about the reality that they see and
refuses to use the words that are
mandated we're destroying the reality
that people are trying to create
and since they see the reality that
they're trying to create as something
that is socially just that they're
trying to bring around bring about a New
Jerusalem someone like me is doing a
very bad thing and should be silenced by
any means necessary including by lying
about me or you know threatening me or
um trying to get me out of my job and so
on
and then your second question was about
social media so why why now and I think
there's a lot of reasons it's a perfect
storm thing
but we are witnessing a social contagion
and that social contagion is carrying
what I increasingly think of as a new
religion a near religion
and it wouldn't be able to spread
without social media and not just
because social media is now in
everybody's Pockets but because of
specifics about social media in
particular the censorship role that
Silicon Valley firms take upon
themselves so I can't speak using the
words that I regard As Natural if I do
I'll just lose my Twitter account
straight away
I have to think about everything I
wouldn't know about such things
yes I know you wouldn't well yeah you
have to be very careful you have to use
their language because that's the
language now of Silicon Valley and so
it's very hard to say what I want to say
using their language okay so now you
dived into the deepest part of this
right off the bat so I think we'll go
we'll talk about the idea that this is a
linguistic battle and then we'll turn
back to the technological front so
um one of the things that I've been
trying to think through because I think
we will go down right down to the weeds
in this to begin with is
the what seems to me to be the
postmodern anti-enlightenment and
anti-judeo-christian insistence that
epistemology which is the model of
reality let's say that we use to guide
ourselves Trump's ontology which is
reality itself and so the
post-modernists insisted that the
meaning of words could only be
adjudicated in relationship to other
words and so they thought of the whole
linguistic Corpus as something like a
massive dictionary where every word only
bore meaning in relationship to other
words and we really did attempt to deny
or downplay the idea that there was an
external Transcendent reality deistic or
objective that could serve as a
corrective to these epistemological uh
propositions and I think that was driven
in part by the underlying Marxist
insistence that let's say power rules
everything but also that human beings
are infinitely malleable and because of
that can be molded and should be molded
in the view of whoever happens to hold
the utopian reins let's say and all of
that's Tangled together and you also
call this a neo-religion and so that's
why I'm bringing up all these additional
factors because I think they play into
this
religious what's become a religious
battle essentially and we should also
talk about why you and I have both of
both concluded apparently that this is
best construed as a religious battle
yeah I mean I agree with every word that
you say and in particular I would say
that the reason that this battle is
being fought on women's bodies
particularly
because if you want to say that sex
isn't real and what people say about
themselves is real
like formally that's symmetric that
should affect everybody but actually it
affects women because women's bodies are
more exigent than men's
so we're the ones who carry the babies
basically
and I think that means that a large
share of all women hit the Bedrock
reality of this is how we make new human
beings
and it's easier for men to ignore that
fact easier for men to think of
themselves as a um a ghost in a machine
or as a little homunculus being carried
around by a meat puppet um as someone
who could become immortal as someone who
could you know cut the fleshly bonds or
that you know we could start doing wound
transplants all these things like if
you've had that experience of growing
another human being and then having to
get it out of you
you're just a much less
um you're just much less amenable shall
we say to these sorts of Illusions and
so here in bris in Britain one of the
major sites of resistance to all of this
is mumsnet which has this reputation as
being a site where you talk about you
know what are the best diapers to buy or
what's the best formula or you know is
my husband being a jerk or whatever but
actually it's also where women talk
about this movement to turn the word
woman into something that just means a
feeling a feeling that can be in a man's
head
okay so so a couple of ideas about that
three of them I guess three ideas the
first is that my understanding of the
anthropological literature in
relationship to initiation rituals in
anachronistic uh tribal communities
let's say or or primordial tribal
communities is that the initiation
rituals for men are more severe
generally than those for women and the
one of the hypotheses about that is that
well women run smack into biological
reality not least in the form of
menstruation but then just but then
definitely in the form of uh pregnancy
and childbirth and so they get initiated
into the actuality of ontology the
Bedrock Reality by Nature whereas that
has to be done culturally with men
and so and then the next thing is you
you said that women have to contend with
biological reality in a way that men
don't because of that
um and that might be true especially
once a woman has been pregnant had a
child which tends to grow people up in a
very radical way but it is also markedly
the case that the people affected by
this uh gender dysphoria epidemic happen
to be young women and young boys and so
that's something that we could talk
about and well maybe we'll just leave
we'll just leave it at that for the time
being
um oh yeah oh sorry the last thing was
you said that it's the reality of
feminine existence that seems to be the
place where this religious Battleground
is taking place and then you tied the
notion of reality to the necessity of
reproduction and that's actually a
really good definition of what
constitutes reality and that
that is relevant to some of the facts
that you laid out in your book so for
example one of the facts is these are
biological and evolutionary facts that
sex emerged
1.2 billion years ago and so that's an
awful long time ago it's way before
trees it's way before many of the things
that we regard as fundamental Cardinal
elements of reality the brain evolved
500 million years ago and the cerebrum
200 million years ago and what this
means is that by the time we developed a
central nervous system and we're able to
conceptualize it all uh
um cognitively speaking sex had been a
biological reality for several hundred
million years and one of the things that
bothered me about the compelled speech
legislation in Canada that mandated that
people use the pronouns of other
people's choice was that I thought two
things I thought number one that that
was an assault on what might be the most
fundamental perceptual category in the
human cognitive
lexicon and perceptual universe that are
are the entire way we we envision
reality has a sex-oriented underlying
symbolic structure and one of the
consequences of introducing this
mandated Primacy of subjective identity
would be the destruction of our ability
to communicate and also the
dissemination of a tremendous amount of
confusion among impressionable young
people so I figured when the pronoun
laws first came to existence that we
would produce a psychogenic endemic
which is exactly what what happened and
that it would particularly affect young
women because that's where psychogenic
epidemics tend to originate if you look
at the historical data and that
confusion psychogenic epidemic and
inability to communicate has stemmed
precisely from this deep philosophical
or even I would say in some sense even
theological move now does any of that
seem to you to be
stating the case to
seriously no not at all I would
completely agree with everything that
you said there so I would say about the
um the psychic epidemic that's playing
out in teenage girls we do see psychic
epidemics in teenage girls first or
worst they are the people who become
anorexic they're the people who
self-harm they're the people who
um went through these hysterical
laughing episodes and so on if you could
look back historically speaking I don't
think anyone knows exactly why but it's
an observable fact at this point
but also I know why oh you know I Can't
Tell You Why yeah well I know some of
why well look when boys and girls are
given personality tests before they hit
puberty there's not a lot of difference
in average level of negative emotion
experienced
but as soon as girls hit puberty their
proclivity to experience negative
emotion so that shame and guilt and
disappointment and fear and depression
is elevated markedly in contrast to men
and it's permanently transformed at
puberty and it stays stable for the rest
of women's lives and so women reliably
experience more negative emotion than
men on average now there's wide
individual difference and there's some
men who experience more negative emotion
than women but we're talking about and
what that means at least in part is that
the people almost all the people who
experience the highest levels of
negative emotion and that would include
self-consciousness and shame are female
and that kicks in at puberty and so it's
interesting I'll add puberty too kids
have to
re-structure their identities in quite a
major way and that's especially true for
girls because they have first of all it
happens to them earlier right so they're
less
mature when Nature comes calling let's
say plus as soon as puberty kicks in
they have these elevated levels of
negative emotion and one of the things
we know this is so interesting as far as
I'm concerned is that if terms that are
reminiscent of self-consciousness
load almost perfectly onto negative
emotion so there's almost no difference
whatsoever between being self-conscious
and and experiencing guilt and shame and
anxiety and so if you add the stress of
puberty and that physical transformation
to the emotional transformation and then
you take an extreme the extreme outliers
on the negative emotion continue it's
all women it's all young women and we
know as well from the literature on
gender dysphoria that the individuals
who experience gender dysphoria
first of all don't have suicidal
ideation or those sorts of symptoms any
more highly than people who experience
non-gender dysphoria psychiatric
disorders so it's a class of General
psychiatric disorder and if they're
associated with negative emotion that's
going to mostly affect young women that
makes such sense and they turn it onto
their own bodies as well like the shame
and themselves get turned onto their
bodies and in particular their breasts
it's not it's not it's not by chance
that they're cutting their breasts off
and you cut it off well it is it is this
self-consciousness at the body level
it's it's clear as well from The
evolutionary uh research so women
evaluate men for physical attractiveness
and sense of humor and intelligence and
so forth but they also evaluate them on
the basis of either social status or
perceived capability to gain productive
social status okay men do not evaluate
women for that but they do evaluate them
on the basis of their physical
appearance and they look for signs of
fecundity and youthfulness and so women
are judged more harshly by each other by
men and by biology itself let's say on
the basis of their physical appearance
and so they have reason to be more
self-conscious and the reason they're
they experience more negative emotion as
far as I can tell at puberty I think
there's three factors that contribute to
that is one is you get physical
dimorphism really emerging at puberty
because boys get to be bigger than girls
and so that means if girls engage in
physical combat with males they're more
likely to be hurt and hurt badly and so
they should be more afraid in those
encounters and they are and then women
are also more sexually vulnerable than
men because they bear the burden of
pregnancy and childbirth and then also
and this is worth thinking about as far
as I can tell is that there's no reason
to assume that women's nervous systems
are adapted to make women comfortable
they might be adapted to make women
hypersensitive to the sensitivity of
infants
and that'll make women more tuned to
environmental dangers and the cost of
that is that women suffer more
emotionally so you could you could
imagine that the female nervous system
might be optimally tuned for the mother
infant dyad and not for the mother
herself and so and then if you add to
that the fact that all of those factors
tend to make women experience more
negative emotion than men and then that
girls run into that young when they hit
puberty then they're casting about for
an explanation for that misery and if
that's provided for them to them by the
context then they can be susceptible to
emotional contagion any and and social
contagion anything that's associated
with explanation for the negative
emotion or any way out of it like
anorexia like cutting like body
dysmorphia they're going to be more
susceptible to that
sociological to those sociological fads
that all sounds incredibly familiar yeah
yeah yeah and and they and they jump
onto whatever whatever's offered to them
and I would say about the the trans
social contagion in particular is it
sold as a 100 immediate solution like
nobody tells an anorexic girl that we
can just switch the anorexia off but
they do say to kids if you if you're
gender dysphoric if you transition
magically you'll be better and that all
your problems will be solved because
your problems stem from not
understanding that you're actually
really a boy
and one other thing I would add I'd be
interested to hear if this resonates
with you
something that feminists have
implemented really for decades is the
way that unlike men there's not very
much age solidarity among women so a
young man may look at a middle-aged man
or even an older man and say that's what
I'd like to be like
whereas younger women I've noticed this
really personally tend to almost despise
at women past the menopause and I think
a lot of what they're saying is that
they don't want to become that person
that women don't want to become their
mothers yeah well that's that that's
pretty awful Isn't it and well I would
say there's a couple of reasons for that
I mean my wife has started a podcast
Series where she's interviewing older
women who've had successful careers in
families to have them lay out the course
of their career and be rigorously
truthful about it I think part of the
reason that there's two reasons maybe
that young women might have that
attitude towards older women and one is
I think that younger women are lied to
almost all the time
and they're lied to partly by older
women I'm not going to put this on older
women right because it's complicated but
you know younger women are told
in no uncertain terms that the only
important thing for them and what will
be vital to their identity and what
should be vital to their identity if
they're decent and honorable and
ambitious young women is their career
and that's simply not true for most
women and it's also not true for most
men by the way it's definitely true for
a subset of men but for most women the
optimal life and I think most women
discover this in their 30s is a
well-balanced aggregation of family
marriage and career and I'll tell you
every time I've made that comment people
have clipped out say three minutes of me
talking about that idea
um I get the most vitriol comments that
I've ever got when I've ever discussed
anything and all of them come from young
women and they're so vicious that it's
beyond it's actually beyond belief and
so that's an echo of what and then well
then the other thing is our entire
culture
has turned viciously against motherhood
you know we we presume that if you're a
moral agent then you shouldn't bring any
more rapacious human beings to expand
the cancerous growth of humanity onto
the planet and that if you're a woman
who wants to be a mother then you're a
second-rate citizen because you've
subordinated your proper desire to have
a career in the patriarchal world to
this anachronistic birth machine
mechanism that you don't want to be
destined to and all of that is
pathological beyond comprehension but
it's also the situation that we happen
to be in right now and I think we
devalue age and in particular we devalue
age in women
like women you know women once they're
past the menopause are no longer seen as
valuable because they're no longer
beautiful and no longer potentially
fertile and I I see the contradiction
between that and what you're saying but
I think both are true
and so young women don't like the
thought that they're going to turn to
older women I mean I remember I was a
young woman once I think too you know
that
to the degree that we devalue family and
and continuity between Generations that
also leaves the vital role of older
women somewhat up in the air because uh
one of the major roles that older women
can play is that is as wise guides to
younger women
making their way through the
complexities of career and family and
also to play out the role of supportive
grandparent and to be there within that
family context and if we devalue family
then we reduce people to their career
and their individual attractiveness and
then if attractiveness on the sexual
front is waning that reduces it to
career and if the career isn't Stellar
then what's the remaining signifier of
value and the answer is well very little
that's a pretty damn dismal uh Prospect
for anybody who anybody who's female
who's moving through the world so yeah
and you don't like to look forward and
see that that's what's coming for you so
that's quite that makes it quite
important not to listen to what older
women say you know to parody what
somebody like me says about say child
safeguarding like to mock it and to say
things like oh won't someone think of
the children well yes I do right and
thanks you know I am a mother yeah I
think it's one of the most important
things I do is think of the children but
that seems mock-worthy to a lot of
younger people and in particularly
strangely to a lot of younger women
well you know you know the other thing
that seems to happen I would say too is
that the social media networks are set
up so that casual derogatory derisive
narcissistic mocking is not only allowed
but staggeringly prevalent and
encouraged it's not at well that's
that's it it attracts attention and is a
courage now you know we have to talk
during our conversation today about the
role that narcissism plays in all of
this yes the mobbing the derives of
online comments and the transsexual
phenomenon itself as well as this claim
that subjective claims to Identity Trump
everything because there is no more
signaling narcissistic claim than that I
am who I say I am and no one else has a
say it's like well really in a marriage
let's say you're just who you say you
are you don't have to negotiate your
identity with your wife or husband you
never do that with your children you
never do that with your friends they
just go along with whatever game you you
want to play every bloody second of your
life do they and if they don't that
makes them evil predators and and valid
targets for derision derision and
mocking and worse than that because as
you know perfectly well this online
mobbing Behavior that's driven by
thoughtless narcissists not only is
psychologically destabilizing because of
its vitriol equality but also can
certainly reach its tendrils into the
confines of your job let's say I mean
it's become impossible for me to work as
a psychotherapist I had to leave my job
at the University because it became
impossible to be for me to function in
both those domains and so
I would say this narcissism is also
encouraged by it's encouraged by
educational institutions because they
take young people in and they say well
you know you're
you're immature mess ionic desire to
save the world which could be admirable
if channeled properly should manifest
itself in this vehement
activism that puts you in position of
ultimate moral authority over your
seniors let's say instantly and that's
what you should be doing and anyone who
opposes that is uh well evil and and
predatory at best and as a consequence
no punishment is too extreme and
alongside that that you must choose your
identity off a list of dozens and
sometimes hundreds like they require the
most intense constant rumination and
self-examination I mean I was talking to
somebody just yesterday who was telling
me that um a child who's 12 now you know
has this check sheet for how do I feel
and this is a really happy child
but you're meant to be thinking all the
time like how am I feeling right now am
I as you know on a scale of one to ten
how happy am I how this am I how that am
I how the other am I this is all
terribly bad idea
well it's clearly it's clearly bad look
look one of the things I learned when I
was treating people who were socially
anxious I had a lot of anxious people in
my uh in my clinical practice which is
hardly surprising because that that's uh
the kind of suffering that requires
people to see clinical intervention
so socially anxious people when they go
into a new social situation
think obsessively about how others are
thinking about them yes and so then they
become self-conscious often about bodily
issues but not only that they might
become self-conscious about their lack
of conversational ability and the fact
that they're not very interesting and
the fact that they're being evaluated by
other people it's a Litany of obsessive
thoughts and you can you might say well
you could train people to stop thinking
about themselves but you can't stop
people from thinking about something by
telling them to stop thinking about
something but what you can train people
to do
is to think more about other people and
so one of the techniques that I used in
my practice was okay now
when you go into a social situation next
time like we'd go through the niceties
of introducing yourself and making sure
they knew your name and get that
ritualized so that it was uh practiced
and expert and therefore not a source of
anxiety but the next thing is your job
is to make the other person that you're
talking to as comfortable as possible to
pay as much attention to them and so we
know that the more you think about
yourself this is literally true
there is no difference between thinking
about yourself
and being miserable they load on the
same statistical axis and so these kids
that are constantly being tormented by
150 identities so that's a a front not
of freedom but of utter chaos and then
asked to constantly reflect on their own
state of emotional well-being and
happiness is the surest route to the
kind of misery that's going to open them
up to
to psychogenic epidemics let's say the
clinical data on that are clear and then
you land into that the idea that you may
have been led to believe that because
you're a not very feminine girl or a not
very masculine boy that that means that
really you are of the opposite sex the
fact is you're not and no one around you
is going to think that you are because
you don't look like the opposite sex and
you become even more self-conscious like
self-consciousness brought you to this
point and now you're hyper aware that
everyone around you doesn't think of
yourself as the way that you've just
presented yourself and then you're
watching for misgendering
and you know you're you're actually
being told that it's a really terrible
thing to do and that no one would do
this unless they really hated you and
they wanted you to die like they want
you to disappear they want trans people
dead they want them gone you know I mean
that's what people say about me that I
want you know to cause a genocide of
some sort and I mean like when did I
ever write such a thing so what what
that is is it's the feeling that you've
put all of your um ability to care about
yourself understand yourself Define
yourself onto other people and how
they're looking at you and they're not
looking at you right they're looking at
you funny
so you you know you you are now out of
control
add to that mix okay so we could add a
couple of other layers so
kids that are well socialized and
popular
develop that ability between the age of
two and four right and what they undergo
this psychological transformation in
identity they go from a two-year-old
egocentrism so the two-year-old can only
play a game with him or herself they
can't play a shared game and so
two-year-olds will play in parallel but
they can't play a joint game and that
means that their identity this is so
important their identity is purely
subjectively defined
and they have temper tantrums if you
interfere with that
okay now between two and four most kids
extend their identity out into the
communal world and so one of the ways
they do that is Imagine two little kids
between the age of say three and five
play in house a little boy and a little
girl the little boy asked little girl do
you want to play house and she'll say
yes and so what that means now is
they've established a joint identity for
for the time span of their play and the
joint identity is that they're both
engaged in the same epistemological
world in the same conceptual world and
then they negotiate roles say well I'll
be the daddy and you be the mummy
and they can flip that rule by the way
and sometimes they will because they
want to play out the other side but
generally they pick a sex-appropriate
role for obvious reasons and then having
established the goal so let's pretend
about the household which is a form of
thought they have to jointly establish
an identity that's acceptable to each
other and then they have to do something
even more sophisticated which is they
have to conduct themselves in those
roles so that the game is fun so that
both people will keep playing and so
that both people want to keep playing
with each other
now it doesn't take much thought to see
that that's exactly that's an analog and
a prodroma to what you actually do as an
adult when you enter a intimate
relationship that's long-term is you
play house in the long run but so what
happens is between the age of two and
four your identity moves from egocentric
and subjectively defined to communal and
negotiate it and now this idea that we
have that your identity is only what you
say it is
appeals not only to
I suppose the ideologues that are
pushing it but it also appeals to people
who are developmentally stuck and I mean
this in the deepest sense are stuck at a
two-year-old level of psychological
development and I think maybe there's a
couple of reasons for that you imagine
there a lot of kids are only kids now
so they're not socialized by their
siblings a lot of kids have older
parents with lots of resources so
they're sheltered in a way that children
never have been
and a lot of kids are exposed to
computer screens and TV screens
at a very early age so they don't have
the opportunity to engage in the kind of
dramatic play that helps them uh develop
an extended social identity and so it's
possible on top of all this that we have
an epidemic of narcissism that's being
capitalized on by the woke ideologues
who are also likely suffering from the
same psychopathology
yes and so you see a lot of things
together you see a lot of
um different needs or um weaknesses or
pathologies that are playing out in sync
with each other and so these children I
I really do think that they're victims
they're they're necessary victims of an
ideology so if you're an adult man who
wishes to be seen as a woman and the
most important thing that you want is to
have people believe that this is in
something innate that people are born
this way
and that means there must be children
who are trans
and it's it's not relevant to you
whether or not that's actually the case
for the individual children the children
of the sacrificial victims of the
ideology and so you've got adults who
are using children as props
for their description of who they are
okay so let's so let's dive into that so
one of the things you do in your book is
you detail out a lot of sexual fetishes
tracing them back a couple of hundred
years so imagine that you're a hyper
masculine male imagine you're a little
narcissistic in your masculinity and
let's say there's a part of your psyche
that regards that as unbalanced
and so what happens is you start to have
fantasies about the value of the
contracexual uh uh temperamental virtues
and those would be the feminine ones but
given that you're not very conceptually
sophisticated maybe the way that
counterbalancing tendency manifests
itself in you is in fantasies of being
female and that that fantasies are so
damn deep that they actually involve
even the sexual impulse so Carl jungle I
think thought more deeply about this
than anyone else believed that as we
move through life that and we expanded
our personalities that we would expand
them beyond the
confines of a rather stereotypical
gender identity and incorporate the
virtues of the sex that we weren't so
that would mean for women that they
would become more emotionally stable and
also more disagreeable as they got older
and for men it would mean that they
became more emotionally vulnerable and
more compassionate as they got older at
least they would extend their capability
into those domains and that was a
necessary part of expansion and maturity
and then if that's forestalled by by
narcissism let's say or even by
inability then the proclivity to develop
those contracexual Tendencies would
start to manifest itself in the kinds of
fantasies that you described as
characteristic of the auto gynophilic
transsexuals and so then if you think
that narcissism is part of what's
driving that right I'm I'm pushing too
hard in the direction that I'm going and
so these fantasies manifest in a
compensatory way that you get a perfect
storm and it's the narcissists who are
doing this that insist upon subjective
identity and who also by the way are
perfectly willing to sacrifice children
to their own purposes absolutely and and
two things that you notice when you look
at these people are one what they're
seeing when they look in the mirror is
not what you're saying
um they're they're seeing they're seeing
a fantasy they're seeing a fantastic
version of themselves but you who are
not in love with this this idea this
idea of the feminine version of this man
you're seeing something a lot less
flattering and that's very hurtful to
them that's experienced I think as a
psychic insult that you know because
because it's like being flipped out of
the fantasy like if you're in this
beautiful fantasy and then someone
laughs
or someone calls you he
and then that that's narcissistic rage
is what you see as the responsibility
that's right that's that's right it's
and it's it's narcissistic rage at in
many ways the same level that you'd see
in a thwarted two-year-old yes yes and
it feels like that when you're at the
receiving end I have to say yeah well
that's for sure I've done both I've felt
both well right and when when you see
when you see these activists on this
front melt down and have a tantrum if
especially if you have a clinical eye or
you've been a parent you think oh my God
like that's that's exactly what
two-year-olds do and that's a hell of an
early developmental level to be fixated
at you know yeah that's really bad
that's really bad that that shows a real
disjunction in in psychological
development so it's no wonder this is
this is felt as seriously affecting by
the people who are affected yes so deep
and it involves core issues of identity
and I think it must be felt very
differently by a man who's looking at us
like you and a woman like me because
it's not just that it's offensive that
this man is doing what looks to me like
a poor and very perotic imitation of a
woman
it's also that I am expected to play
along in a way that it really casts to
me as as a supporting actress in my own
life
and if I step out of Rome the rage that
this brings down is absolutely
extraordinary like you're acceptable as
a woman as long as you're going along
with this and then if you mention any
tiny little bit of need that a woman
might have that just won vulnerability
that a woman needs that really requires
that all males are excluded from
somewhere all males even the males who
identify as women
you are it's as if you it's as if you've
done the worst thing that it's possible
to do it's like saying to the the
two-year-old go to bed or brush your
teeth or no you can't have another
biscuit and it is it's a meltdown I
presume it does feel Dreadful to that
person but it's it's ugly to see it in
an adult oh I'm sure I'm sure it does
well it's terrible if you watch a
two-year-old having a temper tantrum
carefully
and most people won't because they'll
turn away because it's too disturbing if
you watch a two-year-old have a
contemporary tantrum one of the things
you realize is that the overcoming of
their developing ego by those internal
systems of rage and distress is a
catastrophic defeat for the for the
beginning Unity of the individual and so
then what you do if you're a parent with
any clue is that you set up the
environment so that Tantrums are brought
to a halt and eradicated in some sense
in as a form of acceptable behavior as
rapidly as possible and you don't do
that by suppressing the child's capacity
for anger or distress you do that by
integrating the capacity for distress
and anger into a higher order
personality and so and this you said you
talked about this parody element so
let's go into that because I've noticed
this too A lot of the behavior that I
see on the part of people who are aping
women let's say looks to me like a
parody and I think that part of the
reason they get so mad at women who
don't play along is because they also
have this fantasy of women femininity as
merely as passive receptive
all-encompassing you know it's kind of
the counterpart to the submission
element that goes along with dominance
and submission play that you often see
more hyper masculine men attracted to
and so I think that why women when women
stand up for themselves they also
violate the image of docile and
receptive femininity that plays such a
major role in the Fantasy Life of the
people who are engaged in say
cross-dressing so I think that's
absolutely right and I would add
something else to that which is that I
think that both sexes do have a somewhat
and maybe idealized version of what it
is to be a member of the opposite sex
and you know a man may have a fantasy
version of what it you know it's just an
ordinary man an ordinary heterosexual
man who's happily married and has female
friends he may also just have some quite
Fantastical ideas about what it would be
like to be a woman like that you know
you can lie back and let the man do the
work or that it must be lovely to to be
so fragrant all the time or something
you have that you know you have these
very superficial ideas of what it is to
be a member of the opposite sex and
that's true I have to say in pornography
as well like women as imagined by men in
pornography or nothing like real women
just like the men who are written by
women in erotica are nothing like real
men
and you see that too in these what look
to me like parodies but I don't think
they're intended to be parodies they're
not meant to be insulting the man is
describing what he sees I wouldn't be so
sure about that okay interesting I'm
sure about that well because we also
don't know to what degree the vitriol
that's directed towards women that's a
consequence of this narcissism is also a
reflection of a genuine hatred and this
is why we should never forget just
exactly what kind of radical and
revolutionary genius Sigmund Freud
really was yes because Freud put his
finger on the key pathology of our time
even our time more than his because he
regarded the edible complex as the
source of all pathology and the the
edible complex was essentially the
catastrophic consequences of the
non-judgmental
non-discriminating
hyper-compassionate all-accepting
maternal spirit and so Freud's idea was
with something and you can think about
this biologically too Freud's idea was
something like this so human beings are
peculiar among animals
let's say and there are two or three
developmental reasons for this first
were born fetal
so because there's an arms race between
the child's head circumference and the
and the carrying capacity of the female
pelvis for purposes of birth if the
pelvis was any wider in the hole in the
middle any wider then female volatile
everywhere yeah yeah that's right
exactly and so the way we've ironed that
out over evolution is that babies are
born far too young they're born at nine
months instead of two years and their
heads are compressible
and so and that's why the mortality rate
for human babies is so high it's a real
narrow passage into life let's say yes
okay and so what that means is that
humans are hyper are hyper dependent
particularly for the first two years but
then because we also have this amazing
plastic socially constructable brain at
least to some degree we have this
immense period of dependence now the
risk in that is that because we're so
dependent an excess of compassion is
necessary especially in the first six
months because imagine the right it
responds to a human infant under six
months of Ages you're 100 correct about
anything that distresses you one hundred
percent of the time and your needs have
to take priority over absolutely
everything else and mothers have to be
wired to provide that yes now the
problem is so this is why the
psychoanalysts they said the good mother
necessarily fails and so the mother has
this terrible conundrum she has to be
willing to sacrifice herself to this
infant fully but then as the infant
matures she has to sacrifice her own
compassion and pull back and start to
become harsh and more encouraging and
demanding simultaneously now if she has
a man along with her that's easier
because it's easier for him to play that
role and that's a cardinal rule that the
masculine Spirit plays but Freud's point
was well this protracted period of
dependence exposes us to the terrible
risk that we never emerge out of infancy
and the terrible devouring mother is a
symbol of the person for whom compassion
has become a hyper dominant and
devouring force and that is precisely
the pro the political problem of our
time it's that this reflexive compassion
that is now deemed it's deemed morally
necessary that it must govern everything
if you don't feel absolutely 100 percent
story for people as if they're infants
then you're a predator
and and two things that you that I was
thinking when you said that one was that
what I'm doing when I refuse to accept a
man who says he's a woman as a woman
is I'm like the mother who's refusing to
give the infant what he wants which is
really a wicked
personally Predator yeah and and so so
the rage is there I'm I'm stepping out
of role for a woman
and I think the other one is the the
most enraging thing
for anybody is to desperately want to be
something that they can never be or to
desperately want something that they can
never have
and so you know a man who's got himself
into this headspace where he can be a
woman in his own mind
somebody who says no and that no can be
in one millionth of the world it can
just be in one place it could just be in
Rape Crisis Center say that's not good
enough that's not good enough that is
that's taking away the dream and and
being a very bad woman stepping out of
role for a woman
well especially for this hyper idealized
feminine compassionate woman right yes
all encompassing and all loving and all
nurturing and you see this again in
two-year-olds you know I'm just watching
this right now with my grandson
um the most
the most magic word the magic word for
two-year-olds is not please the magic
word for two-year-olds is no yes I would
say 20 of the utterances of a
two-year-old is no and that's because no
is the word you use to give yourself
some space in some sense and so
two-year-olds don't like it when you say
no to them it makes them mad and they
push the boundaries as they should
because they need to find where the
boundaries are that's what you should do
when you're two and if if you haven't
had those boundaries organized for you
in a systematic way that enables you to
expand your personality so that you can
find alternative Cooperative roots to
adaptation and you just face this
arbitrary no or you don't face it at all
then you're going to end up being a
person for whom no is uh well it has the
same effect on you as it does on a
recalcitrant two-year-old it demolishes
your entire emotional being the same way
that no know demolishes the world of a
two-year-old yeah I mean and the strange
thing the very strange thing is that
sometimes this is described as you know
conservative or even libertarian values
so I just saw somebody here recently say
um I'd like to see the conservative
party here in England make the case for
self ID the conservative case for a self
ID that it's not anybody else's business
to tell you who that's that's rubbish
exactly exactly misinterpretation yes
well the idea that identity is
subjectively defined is utterly
preposterous it doesn't apply it doesn't
apply in any situations where there's
more than one person involved and then
this weird Devolution of that idea it's
like well not only do you get to say
exactly what you are
now first of all we could talk about
what you are what what you are means but
the second part of that is and it
depends on your feeling well what is
that feeling is that your moment to
moment balance between positive and
negative emotion that's now the Arbiter
of reality itself and then what are you
well the answer to the question what are
you is
it depends on the context and we
actually know this personality
researchers know this so we all have a
temperamente that's partly biologically
instantiated and partly socially
constructed but if you look at how much
our innate temperament
measures of our innate temperament can
be used to predict our behavior from
situation to situation it tops out at
about nine to sixteen percent
so that means and maybe 25 in the case
of IQ which is the most powerful
temperamental Factor we know 75 of what
determines your outcome even on the
cognitive front is social context and
that means like the progressives
claim to to to to to to believe that
about 80 percent of your personality is
socially negotiated 80 percent
and that so that and so also what that
means is imagine you're temperamentally
extroverted
and so you want to talk like I do all
the bloody time I'm still going to shut
up mostly in a funeral right right right
now I might be the most talkative person
at the funeral
right but I'm still gonna use the
context to regulate my behavior and what
that means is that the context actually
defines my identity
and that's how it should be that's what
happens if you're a civilized person is
the context defines your identity
period the end yeah and then the strange
thing that layers on top of that is that
not only are they saying that how you
feel defines Who You Are
they're saying that it defines who you
are that you're a woman or you're a man
when those are just about the most you
know concrete things about us the most
non-negotiable things about us the most
Bedrock things about us like far more
than our IQ well they might be the most
Bedrock thing about us right which maybe
is why the culture war is centering on
this issue because it is a war between
epistemology and ontology or between
let's say narcissistic delusion and
reality itself then the battle devolves
to Identity on the grounds of sex right
is what it what did Freud say biology is
Destiny yeah and I mean I don't believe
that entirely well it isn't true
entirely well on top of biology we have
you know we have got this civilization
that we've built and it's very it's very
Anchorage to biology of course it is but
it is also to some extent malleable like
we do co-negotiated in different
societies to some extent on top of that
but then to have this idea that a man
can say
I wish I was a woman or I feel like I'm
really a woman or I think I'm a woman
Inside which are things that only a man
can say I can't wish to be a woman
I can't feel like I should have been a
woman those are things that are only
possible for men
and then those things are meant to make
you a woman
and then it's so detached from reality
that there's there's no tether it can go
anywhere like this can just float off to
anything at all and that's why we see
this weird proliferation of you know a
poorer gender or somebody being gray
sexual or something you know it goes off
into sort of almost stamp collecting
levels of
of precision and difference and so on
well there's another issue that comes up
there too is is so
this is relevant to your claim which is
entirely warranted that
vary on top of our biology and so for
example there is a lot of biological and
socially constructed variants in
temperament on top of biological sex and
so you you could say without fear of
error that a reasonable percentage of
boys have a feminine temperament and so
that would mean they're they have more
negative emotion
they're more compassionate and they're
more interested in people than in things
those are the Cardinal differences
between the masculine and The Feminine
and a non-trivial number of boys have
those characteristics just like a
non-trivial number of girls are less
compassionate and polite so more
competitive let's say they're more
emotionally stable and they're more
interested in things now those are
relatively rare girls and relatively
rare boys but statistically they're
hardly uh what would you say they're
hardly
they're not so rare that you don't see
them all the time it might be 10 if boys
are essentially feminine in their
temperament 10 of girls and that's a lot
and what that should and so that's at
the level of temperament which is really
where gender should be conceptualized
because there are no good measures of
gender there are good measures of
temperament and interest that
differentiate men and women like if you
if you use measures of temperament
including interest
you can reliably identify someone as a
man or a woman about
eighty percent of the time something
like that so you can do it 50 50 on the
basis of chance and with the good with
the best measurements we have you can
get that up to 75 25 or 80 20. but
that's certainly by no means perfect
identification and so one of the things
that's perverse about this too isn't it
is that
despite the claims of the radicals that
identity is socially constructed and
variable
their fundamental notion is that if you
have a variable temperament so if you're
a feminine boy then what that means is
that your biological reality is out of
sync yes because the biology is so
fundamentally important in that case but
never in any other case yes yes it's so
incoherent man it's unreal it can
completely and I mean also if we were to
say which would be a terrible thing to
say and I don't say it if we were to say
that this 10 or 20 percent of boys who
are actually statistically speaking more
like the standard for girls if we were
to say well actually they're really
girls that's not what we're seeing
there's no objective claim here that
would at least be semi-objective it
would be absolutely repulsive as well
they're just
slightly out of the ordinary boys you
know but it's the people who were
claiming that a man can tell you he's a
woman or a woman can tell you she's a
man
you know there's no there's no way you
could say now you're actually just very
like a man so you can't be a woman like
in particular he could be a rapist
which is the most masculine thing you
know so we don't even say that a trans
woman who commits rape thereby
demonstrates of this claim to be in some
gendered way really a woman has has been
disproved
yes so in your book you also talk about
oh yes so there's another element that's
at work here too and that and that is
the uh the trans Transformations are
also on The Cutting Edge of
um a transhumanism that's also aimed at
the in some sense at the eradication of
death itself right so there's another
utopian dream that's sitting underneath
this which has its positive element I
would say too because we are trying to
improve the length of our life and to
rejuvenate ourselves and there's an open
question here is well how far can the
transformations of our identity go in an
increasingly technological world and how
far should they go
and so and the transhumanist types who
who believe for example that our
Consciousness could be uploaded into a
computer and that we could be propagated
forever also have a proclivity to fall
into the camp that says that your
identity is only what you say it is
right it's this Soul idea that's that's
independent of the body and there's a
wish in that to be free of the chains
and constraints of of mortal existence
and and you can understand that as well
but it's but running away from something
into fantasy is not the way to address
it
I mean it is a fantasy isn't it and it's
a fantasy that's rather similar to being
of the opposite sex the fantasy that
you know you can control death itself
that life and death are in your hands
it's the fantasy of being a God not just
being Immortal but being a god
and sometimes people Express that as um
you know terribly light ways to talk
about what are major operations like
anyone who's been through sex
reassignment surgery as it's called
although of course we can't actually
reassign sex we'll tell you that this
was a major operation
and the question of how um how content
you are what the outcome depends a lot
on how realistic your ideas about it
beforehand were so if you're someone
who's lived with gender dysphoria for
many years and you do it then you know
it may actually just make you feel a bit
better but if you thought you could be
turned into the opposite sex you will be
disappointed because these are we are
not made of meat Lego
I also don't think that the data that
this actually makes people feel better
is really very clear I'm not sure at all
that the tiny minority of people that we
help first of all are truly helped yeah
um because there's so much idiot
ideology obscuring this and so much
self-deception and narcissism on the
part of the people who are doing it and
undertaking it that we don't have clear
data but what we bloody well do know is
that a huge number of people who are
doing this have been pulled into a
psychogenic fad and then are undergoing
unbelievably dangerous hormonal
transformation because hormones are no
joke they are powerful physiological
agents and then the surgery itself is
well it couldn't it if the only way it
could be more brutal in a fundamental
sense is if it was done without
anesthetic right this is not something
you Waltz into for one day and and uh
and then like it's a minor modification
of some
trivial element of your identity these
are life-changing procedures
exactly as well you know that you can go
through the opposite sex puberty or that
you know the the Wilder reaches of the
the trans Lobby will talk about things
like putting all children on puberty
blockers until we grow up enough that we
decide which puberty we want to undergo
and I mean I I was brought up Catholic
I'm no longer a Believer at all but I
listen to this and I just think that's
that's demonic actually
to say that to children to give children
that idea I think you know whoever
whosoever misleads one of these children
you know it's the worst thing you can do
and they do yeah every time well so well
so let me ask you about this then you
know one of the things that I have
noticed is that people tend to come to
religious convictions not so much when
they discover the nature of good but
when they discover the nature of evil
and the reality of evil and you call you
know you described yourself as a lapsed
Catholic let's say but you've been
talking about the Battle that's been
happening right now in religious and
Theological terms and I think that
indicates the depth of the battle and
then also making the case that well the
willingness to sacrifice children to the
dictates of a narcissistic ideology
borders on the demonics pretty strong
language for someone who's not religious
and so one of the things I've been
concerned about is that when God dies to
use the nietzschean phrase that and we
no longer attribute to God what is God's
and attribute to Caesar what is Caesar's
we start to attribute to Caesar what is
God's and that contaminates the
political with the religious and so I
think that even if you're a secularist
you have to start to understand if
you're sophisticated that some elements
of
the axioms of perception and cognition
themselves are so deep they're so
fundamental that they're outside the
realm of the political they might even
be outside the realm of the
philosophical they're down in the realm
of the Sacred and that's true okay okay
so why why what given your lapsed
Catholic State let's say
it it's weird right because there's this
there's this ambivalence in in your
conceptualization I I don't I don't feel
I'm diagnostic about this yeah okay okay
so I'd like to hear about about so I
don't describe myself as elapsed
Catholic because really I just don't
believe at all anymore but the reason I
don't believe is that I don't think it's
true
it's not because I can't feel the
emotional and spiritual content of
what's being said it's that I think if
it's factually false and maybe that just
shows my lack of poetry and Imagination
as a human being but I can't get past it
anyway however
I do think that there is something
sacred in the creation of a new life by
a couple and a mother who grows a baby
for nine months I've done it twice it
was it's not something that you could or
should talk about in monetary or
financial or economic terms or even in
prosaic everyday terms it's something
extraordinary it's it's a miracle in
secular terms you you've you've done
something miraculous
and then children are such precious
little things you know like I feel that
as a mother I feel it as a sister of
eight younger siblings is now an aunt to
19 children you know it's
it's not something that we should treat
so lightly and I because I was brought
up Catholic as an Irish Catholic the
language that I turn to I have no other
language to use for how seriously I take
the wrong that is being done look in my
in my clinical practice it was always
the case that when I was dealing with
the most fundamental catastrophes of
people's lives or the most profound
experiences of their lives that the
language would automatically become
religious yes and that was the case even
if the people that I were was talking to
were explicitly a religious or
secularist and the reason for that is
that we actually have a domain of deep
language and when we fall into the
domain of deep language we're in the
domain of the Sacred and I've been
trying to think about that technically
so imagine this you know we have this
notion of literary depth right some
stories are shallow some stories are
deep okay and everyone feels that and
everyone pretty much accepts the fact
that same with music the same with
beauty any art form there's shallow
aspects and there are deep aspects and
deep aspects move you and they move you
deeply so they have emotional resonance
and they call to you as well right they
call you to a better version of yourself
and part of the depth so imagine that
the deeper an idea is is precisely
proportionate to the number of other
ideas that that I that depend on that
idea
right and so then as we move down Into
the Depths and we start talking about
well the category of sex for example or
that that Stellar Purity and
attractiveness of children which you
really see if you can see children
you're way down in the depths when you
see that that's how children reward you
for having them right is that there's
such a responsibility and such a miracle
at the same time that the miracle of the
relationship that you can have with them
amply repays you for the responsibility
if you're if you can only see it but
then you have to go down Into the Depths
and take that relationship as a sacred
reality and and ethical requirement and
yeah you deal with those things casually
at your great Peril and and it's funny I
mean I said that you don't use the
language of economics about them but I
mean there is something I often think
and I say it in a jokey way but I'm
completely serious too
I mean a child is the ultimate
non-fungible good right fungible things
are the things that it doesn't matter
which one it is one goal piece of gold
bullion is the same as another one but a
barrel of oil is the same as another one
child is not the same as another and if
you lose a child you can't replace that
child
so why is that like why do we feel like
that well obviously in my opinion
Evolution gave it to us uh a religious
person might conceive of that
differently but the feeling is the same
and I find now in ways that before I
found this topic I have fruitful and
interesting to me at least conversations
with religious people because they take
this seriously
to them you know that they feel a sense
of awe at god well right that oh well
what you see I think when you have a
relationship with a child that your own
child in particular because you can see
them most clearly in some real sense is
that you see
the
manifestation of the image of God
I mean to me it's the it's evolution is
the thing that did that but evolution
gives us a sense of awe you know you
don't it's not something you treat
lightly it's not something that isn't
miraculous and this seems like maybe
we've gone off topic a lot but I think
it's why mothers
and people who care about child
protection are among the people who are
most disturbed by what's happening here
because if you take children seriously
and if you take the task of creating a
world in which little human beings can
turn into healthy whole responsible good
adults who can live full-rounded
satisfying lives that are not just good
for themselves but good for the other
people around them you know that's again
I have to turn to the sacred language
like this is a sacred task and to see
people so willfully tell small children
lies like that you can be either sex if
you want or that sex is a spectrum or
that but we're assigned a sex at Birth
or that some people are non-binary or
that if you you know if when you're
seven you decide that you're really a
boy you'll just go on puberty blockers
and take testosterone and there'll be a
little operation and
I I feel livid at these people really
livid yeah I I feel exactly the same
well hence my Banning from Twitter let's
say and I've taken a lot of flack about
that you know when people tell me well
you were so mean to Ellen Page and I
think well you know Ellen Page is a star
and she advertised her transformation
and made the claim that this has
revolutionized her life and then she
displayed her new body in a public forum
and got
1.7 million Instagram likes for it and
probably enticed well let's say one
young girl who's confused into becoming
sterile which is one too many for me but
it could be as many as what a hundred
five hundred a thousand and I have my
tendency to feel a hell of a lot more
sorry for a set of confused isolated and
lonely pubescent girls who have no one
to love them enough
to help them appreciate who they are
than I do for one over privileged and
unfortunately confused narcissistic
Hollywood star yeah I feel the same I
mean I don't particularly want to say
anything about Ellen Page I think you've
said
you said it and I've said it no no I
wasn't going to say I was gonna say
you've said it clearly enough
I would just de-personalize it and I
would say that it's back to the
narcissism the focus on one person
at the expense of everybody else so
that's one of the things that's most
remarkable about this movement is you
know there are many people who are
suffering or underprivileged or
vulnerable or indeed like really really
really hard done by like a colleague of
mine once said to me why are we not
talking about their CDs why are we not
talking about child abuse victims why is
the suffering trans person or the the
untransitioned trans child the Martyr
figure of all
yeah yeah so and why if you know why is
it as if to to sort out that child's
like the worst thing that's ever
happened to anybody to feel gender
dysphoria I think most people feel
gender dysphoria in some respect
um why to sort that out will we
sacrifice any number of other people
it's a form of narcissistic
self-consciousness I mean and everyone
does feel that for sure and I think they
feel that most acutely at puberty I mean
people are well we know we're mortal we
know our flaws we know we're going to
die we know we aren't canonical examples
of our sex that we could be much better
in a thousand ways than we are we all
have to bear that burden and so that
dysphoria that's mortality dysphoria and
it can manifest itself in all sorts of
ways and that's part and parcel of The
Human Condition but to entice young
people into assuming that radical
surgical transformation is the sure cure
for that is well I also believe that it
borders on the Demonic I compared the
people who were doing site doing a
transformation surgery on on minors to
people who sacrifice children to moloch
and I do see it in exactly the same way
and the weird thing about having done
that you know this is so strange too is
that
almost all the comments I got for that
article from the Telegraph and also on
my YouTube channel almost all of them
were supportive yeah way more than I
thought there would be and I thought
well if everyone agrees that this is
wrong
why the hell are we doing it
I mean false consciousness people
believe that other people don't agree
with them I mean that is one of the
purpose of conversations like this is to
show people that you can actually say
these things and I mean it hasn't been
easy for either you or me and we have
had significantly let's talk let's talk
about that I want to know like I know
what happened to me yeah when you wrote
this book what happened to you
I mean not as much as might have because
my employer isn't a coward
so it turns out that you don't need very
much bravery to stand up to these people
because
um the viciousness gets worse if you
give in in any way oh yeah so yes you've
seen that you've seen that if somebody
says something and then they apologize
they just come after you with redouble
ferocity
so I don't think that the editor of The
Economist agreed with me at least at
first but she doesn't like bullies and
she does like free speech and so the
first people tried to get me fired she
told them sharpish where to put it okay
so you had employer support yes employer
support is very important
I often think about what happens to
people in this social media age and in
particular those of us who talk on trans
issues but also those who talk on Race
issues as being the modern form of the
pillory
you're ashamed rather than um injured
you're not you're not hanged or
crucified you're specifically shamed
that's the aim and it's done in a way so
as to maximize the fear that other
people feel that they will also suffer
the same fate because there's nothing
they can do to help you if you're
brought to the pillory like if a woman
is brought to the pillory let's just say
a woman because I'm a woman another
woman could go and stand by her to show
solidarity but it wouldn't do her any
good
she too would be shamed then it would
just mean that there were two outcasts
instead of one so then you think like
what do you do to end the pillory it's
not mass solidarity actually it's um
it's powerful people
you if you are under the protection of
somebody with Social Capital you
wouldn't you wouldn't suffer this fight
this was for the outcasts so it's
actually the job of employers and
institutions to stand up here you mean
rather than to censor for example yes
and you don't have to say very much like
Kathleen stocks at University did
eventually say some good things about
Free Speech but she had been going for
three years and they had said nothing if
the first time they attacked her the
university had said very clearly we
support Free Speech we support academic
freedom we do not tolerate attacks on
our staff I guarantee you the mob would
have gone elsewhere straight away
instead it was made clear that she was
available to be brought to the pillory
so I didn't have that okay so then next
question is why do you think
what has changed that has made our
institutions so utterly cowardly in the
face of the narcissistic minority mob
because something's changed it wasn't
like this 10 years ago you could see it
a bit it certainly wasn't like this 20
years ago so is it is it do you think it
is it fundamentally the power that
social media has brought to the to the
obsessively and narcissistically
outraged minority or what do you think
it is yeah so I think that plays a part
but the thing is your employer can do
the same thing about social media they
can just put out a short statement
saying We Stand by Helen Joyce or
Kathleen stalker whoever it is
she's an excellent journalist journalist
or she's an excellent academic move on
and they move on they really do move on
so it's the it's the fact that
institutions haven't learned to deal
with social media they think they have
to engage I don't know why they do that
it's stupid I've seen it repeatedly okay
so I have a hypothesis about that okay
you tell me what you think of this well
look if you're a conservative type you
tend to be conscientious the
conscientious people tend to be guilt
prone because they they want to be seen
to do their Duty and they want to do
their Duty and so what that means is
that if you're if you're a narcissist
and a mob of 30 torch-bearing Neighbors
show up on your doorstep and tell you
that you're shameful you don't care
because you're a narcissist you're low
in conscientiousness you're parasitic
you're disagreeable you could care less
what other people think and so the mob
has no effect on you but if you're
conscientious and 30 people show up then
you're gonna think well 30 people
wouldn't be on my doorstep if I hadn't
maybe done something wrong and I'm not
perfect and so maybe I should scour my
conscience and you know repent of my my
sins publicly because
well why would I presume I'm right when
I know I'm imperfect that works really
well on conscientious people and now
with with the social media networks a
mob from anywhere in the world can
aggregate itself and even if it's one
person in a million who's annoyed at you
if a hundred million people are watching
then a hundred people can show up on
your doorstep with torches and
pitchforks and so I think that this
guilt targeting that the narcissistic
Psychopaths use in social media is
particularly effective on decent
conservative traditional people and so
they need to learn that we're not in
Kansas anymore
things are not the way they work yeah
you know if you're prepared for it if
you know it's coming
so I think the economist because it's
very America focused but it's still a
very British publication I think it had
a couple of years notice
that things were different and so when
these started you know they they were
they were prepared because it's how you
it's the first thing you do that's
catastrophic if you make a misstep on
the very first thing then it's very hard
to regain it because they know that
you'll give way you've proved it so they
will never leave you alone
yeah well I noticed for a while I've
been subscribing to The Economist
forever such a great magazine and I
noticed over the last six or seven years
that uh an alarming degree of wokeness
had crept into its hallowed hallways and
then I noticed about three years ago
that the tide had turned and that people
had woken up so to speak to some degree
at The Economist and started to push
back against a fair bit of this nonsense
and I was so relieved about that and so
I don't know if that's
I don't know if that's commensurate with
your experience there but thank God
there are some institutions that still
have the ability to stand up and say no
like a like a firm and caring parent
let's say I I shouldn't really comment
on my own employer who've been very good
to me so you know I still hold fast to
some of those older values of discretion
and loyalty and so on that are so easy
for the modern identitarian narcissist
to hijack and to use against you so I
think that's another thing that we're
seeing we're seeing the rise of the
toxic underling I call it in my mind you
know we all know yeah right that what
toxic bosses are like like a toxic boss
can ruin everybody's experience in an
entire workplace but that's like a
that's like a right-wing toxicity in
that it's the it's the toxicity that's
enabled by Authority chain of commands
um loyalty discretion obedience you know
these values that are good and bad of
the of the right wing and now you
imagine you've got a toxic underling
who's somebody who's completely
convinced of their own rightness who's
Junior who's willing to tell any lies in
the service of what they see is the
greater good who have no loyalty
whatsoever who think that the
institution is irremediably sexist
racist transphobic homophobic everything
phobic
and who think that it's their job to to
you know to fight from the bottom up and
then what I was going to say the second
thing that stands along social media as
the enabling factor in all of this is
the rise of the Dei industry diversity
equity and inclusion oh yes and the
thing is if you were living in the old
world if we were still living in Kansas
that would not be too bad because yes
okay we could have some more diversity
that'd be great you know Equity is not a
bad thing in itself and I don't want to
exclude anybody of course but we're not
in Kansas we're living in a new world
where everything is upside down and so
within that world Dei is weaponized and
it creates this Sunderland phenomenon
whereby just some Junior person can
cause an entire organization to have a
meltdown by claiming you know phobias of
various sorts and by taking to social
media to talk about it and bosses don't
feel like they can say and that's
ridiculous you know out if you're going
to talk about us like that because if
they do they'll be told that they're
racist sexist homophobic transphobic
everything else right but you know what
well it but there isn't there is an
unbelievable amount of
self-delusional cowardice in that too
because you can say to those people
there was a rebellion at penguin random
house when the news came out that they
were going to publish my new book oh I
read about it yeah yeah and my daughter
and I are a response to penguin was hey
look uh you got six or seven employees
here in the greatest Publishing House in
the world and they just told you they're
perfectly willing to ban books they
haven't read and then have a meltdown
about it
hey they just told you who you should
fire why don't you fire them and the
answer was well we can't do that it's
like well not only can you do that you
were actually morally obliged to do that
because they showed you in the deepest
possible way that their values which
were narcissistically sensorial were at
100 percent odds with yours the trick is
to not hire those people like not even
to have them come in and prove to you
that they should never have been hired
and there have been a few really
interesting articles about these
meltdowns that I've read in the past few
weeks and there was a sort of a just
just a couple of sentences that were by
the by in one of them and it was it was
a lot of employee of them employers
especially in Washington in the NGO and
non-profits and charitable sector you
know and they were saying how they can
get no work done anymore but they just
can do nothing the entire organization
is tied up in these interminable slack
Channel just conversations about you
know how they need to rearrange and
everything and they're not actually
doing their charitable or their
non-profit Mission anymore they've
stopped being Mission focused at all and
one of them said we realize belatedly
that we have suffered less than some
other people because
and he didn't mention who it was and we
have someone on staff who a year or two
ago was caught up in one of these
horrendous social media dragons and so
the social justice Warriors won't apply
to work here so they were kind of
inoculated against it so I think that's
a trick to work at how you don't hire
these people and I think it's by stating
your values really really clearly and
that those values must be outward facing
there must be to do with your mission
that the mission comes first and that
everybody is expected to sign up
well that's also a reflection of the
belief in that underlying ontological
reality right we actually have a job to
do yes it's a job in the real world and
it's of Paramount importance and what
you if you don't feel like that job is
worth doing then this isn't the job for
you all right well we're coming up at
the end of our half hour or hour and a
half um I'm going to continue talking
about these issues with Helen on The
Daily wire plus Channel we're going to
actually go into the uh details of the
development of her career and and expand
that into a philosophical discussion
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com